[Music]
i'm in the lobby of ramsey solutions on
the debt free stage with a question from
san bernardino california justin and
sherry are with us hey guys how are you
good hi welcome welcome how can ken and
i help
so we're both teachers out in southern
california and uh cool what do you teach
i teach economics we actually use your
curriculum oh thank you changed the
lives of a lot of young people thank you
yeah thank you
and uh i teach i teach robotics grades
seven through 12. wow nice
so i've been teaching for 19 years she's
been teaching for 22 years and
for reasons i won't you already know uh
we love our lives in california our
family's there but we i don't think we
can stay in california anymore so we
came out here we have fall break uh this
week and we came out for just originally
when we booked you know airbnbs and and
the airplane it was just for vacation
um
we're going to the grand ole opry
tonight that's why i'm wearing a silly
shirt but i love it she told me not to
wear it but anyways it's all good yeah
it looks fantastic hey man you're right
you're gonna fit right in yeah right
but anyways uh so we came out for
vacation and and a few things happened
right before
our governor is crazy and stuff and uh
it
i think
it turned into more like a scouting trip
and so um
we're here in uh nashville area and then
we're going um tomorrow to chattanooga
and to check things out in tennessee
it's beautiful
the one hang up that we have is
we looked at the
salaries and we would lose about a
hundred thousand dollars if if we came
here per year per year
yeah they is all about seniority in
california not performance unfortunately
and so that's a hang up um
48 my wife is 46 and we'd be like the
new guy
at a job and that's we're having a
little trouble with that and then um we
do both of our folks are there they're
in their
early to mid 70s so
i guess i kind of know i think i know
what y'all would say but um what do you
think we would say well
i think you'd say go for it but i don't
know i
um
i guess i just wanted your advice and
clarity
we were thinking it's actually like a
million dollar we have 10 more years at
least to retire so it's like a million
dollar decision on income but happiness
might be more important than
well that's that's that's assuming you
would not get any raises during that ten
years that's right and that's also
assuming cost you didn't assume in the
cost of living adjustment plus we don't
have a state income tax here so i think
this is really you're taking an
emotional
decision and you're only applying the
mathematics you need to apply the
mathematics the financial but you also
have to look at the other side of this
and and that's and that's why you want
to leave and the life you want to live
and so i think you walk through the
numbers so okay let's talk about this so
do you have any debt where yet
financially with your retirement what's
it going to look like
uh well we we followed your plan we've
taught the class uh four times i believe
um we've just paid off our house last
may we have no debt we haven't had debt
for 10 years we did the debt free of all
of our debt like maybe about 10 years
ago
and so we have no debt at all we just
how much is your house worth right now
house is worth about 450 000
okay
all right
and then what do you think the salary
range is going to be based on what
little research you've been able to do
here in tennessee what's it going to
look like for both of you
about 65 000 dollars each correct yeah
okay okay that's probably pretty close
yeah yeah
so 130 and you're currently making 230
between the two correct perfect okay wow
wow
okay minus 15
for
income tax right state income tax yeah
right and we've noticed that things are
yeah are the food cheaper things are
cheaper we're finding yes
cost of living on non-housing items
would be different but it's not going to
be 25 different it's going to be 10 5
here there it's not i mean it's not like
a gallon of gas is different in
tennessee than it is in california not
much anyway
um the biggest issue would be the tax
savings um and housing differences
are dramatic obviously um so
it's probably not a million dollar
decision it's probably a half a million
dollar decision
give or take maybe maybe cost of living
adjusted and tax adjusted something like
that uh over a 10-year period of time
um and
well you would give you'd be getting
raises there you'd be getting raises
here so we would just call that yeah
that's fair okay interesting that's a
lot
that's a lot
and so um i i think you ask yourself um
you know a book i wrote the worst
selling book i ever did had a great
saying in it
it's called more than enough it was a
total flop but uh i only sold like i
think i sold like 100 000 copies or
something compared to my other books it
was a flop yeah i'd like to point out a
public service announcement that's not a
flop but anyway it was it was a
follow-up to one that sold 2 million so
that's what you call a flop so but the
anyway in that book
this saying and it's a weird little
saying but it's true
only people only change when the pain of
same
where we are today
exceeds
the pain of change
and so the scale is
it's not a math scale it's how much pain
are you in
there
is it enough to say
i
this is scary and there's obviously a
down it's obviously a pay cut
we can call it whatever it's going to be
a pay cut 300 to 500 000 over 10 years
um are you in that much pain and you
don't have to answer that today on the
camera that's not fair to you but that's
the that's the heart question
the question your heart has to answer
um once you leave here and you go back
home you go this is home
this is where my stuff is it's a
beautiful state
i mean uh there's lots of crazy but it's
a beautiful state yes sir and a lot of
wonderful people there yes
and so you know and you've had great
careers there and you've got great
memories there your parents are there
you can run back over see the parents
that's an airline ticket that doesn't
bother me okay we can get back over
there if they're if they're in trouble
they need some help you can get over
there that's not it's a three-hour
flight you can be there in no time lots
of six flights a day or whatever
non-stop to la it's not uh not a problem
but uh
i got a quick question a lot of roots
coming out of the ground here a lot of
roots i want to play into this math
thing a little bit i just want to wonder
together for a moment
what do you each love if you can give me
two or three words each what do you love
most about your profession
not don't give me environment or
anything i'm talking about the work
itself what do you love most about
teaching
i love seeing the light bulb go on in my
students okay good good answer um i i
live i teach in a 100 percent brain
introduced lunch school
and so
uh you can make a huge difference with
kids that have nothing like nothing
going on for them at all so
uh being able to see that you're moving
the needle yeah yeah i bet you are the
reason i asked that was twofold okay
number one i wanted you guys to hear
yourself say what really brings you joy
and meaning in your work and you can do
that in tennessee the second thing i was
just curious about is
you guys are young enough that you could
come to tennessee and take that same
type of work that you love and that
result that matters to you and
potentially transition into a completely
different than public education but a
career where you are training and
instructing because when i look at
teachers i look at a root word of what
they love the most and this the
functional thing that they love passion
what i call passion work you love is
training or instruction would you agree
with that yes sir but the missional
result which is the result of the work
that that we all long for a mission that
drives us for you all it's influence
so where could you do that in tennessee
that's not in a traditional education
environment that wouldn't take you maybe
that long to get qualified for you don't
have to answer that i'm simply giving
you that as food for thought
do you start a a simple a primitive
version of that is do you start a
tutoring thing on the side
when you get to tennessee texas or
another state not to be here i mean we
love our state but um
the whole point is the conversation is
not about tennessee versus california
the con the conversation's about what
how to make a move and how to
think through it critically and that's
what you're doing you're doing a great
job congratulations you guys proud of
you